Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour.
Je m’appelle Emma Oliveira
et je suis psycho-criminologue
à la direction centrale
de la police judiciaire.
Je sais que mon métier
impressionne souvent
mais il faut savoir que même
si je côtoie la violence et la mort
depuis maintenant seize ans,
je me pose exactement
les mêmes questions que vous.
Qu’est-ce que la mort ?
Quand et comment vais-je mourir ?
Je n'ai pas élucidé ce mystère.
Je peux tenter de vous aider
et vous faire quelques prédictions.
Statistiquement, je dirais que 30%
de cette salle décédera d’un cancer,
27% de maladies cardio-vasculaires,
tout autant
de complications respiratoires.
Quelques-uns mourront de vieillesse,
4,5% d’un accident,
2% risquent de se suicider.
Et peut-être que l’un
d’entre vous rejoindra
les 0,15% de morts violentes.
Est-ce que le mystère est résolu ? Non.
Si je rajoute que dans le monde,
109 personnes meurent par minute,
c’est-à-dire presque deux par seconde,
que c’est une fatalité
à laquelle personne n’échappe
et que tôt ou tard,
vous rejoindrez ce compteur,
ça ne vous éclaire pas non plus, désolé.
Mais la raison est simple,
ces chiffres n’ont absolument
aucun sens pour votre cerveau.
La mort n’est pour lui qu’un concept
qui lui est totalement étranger,
une simple théorie dont la pratique
ne concerne que les autres.
C’est bien pour cela que
le fumeur continue d’ignorer
le « fumer tue » de son paquet
ou que 80% des gens à vélo
ne mettent pas de casque.
Si vous êtes sceptique,
essayez d’imaginer votre propre mort.
Alors, qu’est-ce que ça donne ?
Instinctivement,
beaucoup vont penser à leur enterrement.
Qui sera là ? Qui sera triste ?
Où est-ce que ça aura lieu ?
D’autres vont avoir envie
de rédiger leur testament,
ce qui permet de maîtriser l’après-soi.
Certains, plus visionnaires, vont essayer
d’imaginer ce que le monde deviendra
dans 50 ans, 500 ans,
1000 ans pour les plus imaginatifs.
Dans tous les cas, on se positionne
toujours en spectateur,
donc un peu présent car l’absence,
notre absence,
n’a, comme je vous l’ai dit,
absolument aucun sens.
Alors, il est vrai que certains
vont aller au-delà du concept
et frôler une certaine réalité.
Je pense notamment
aux survivants d’un accident,
d’une agression ou d’un attentat.
On se rend compte que pour le cerveau,
cette expérience exceptionnelle a
principalement des conséquences néfastes.
Ils vivent ce que l’on nomme cliniquement
l’effraction du réel de la mort.
Ce qui se traduit le plus souvent
par une panoplie
de symptômes post-traumatiques,
comme des flashbacks, des réminiscences,
des insomnies, des désordres alimentaires,
de l’anxiété, voire de la dépression,
que le cerveau peut mettre
des années à surmonter.
Pourtant, le processus de départ,
le déclencheur est simple.
La vie apparaît pour la première fois,
de manière brutale,
dans toute sa mortalité, si je puis dire.
Ce qui va changer fondamentalement
leur perception d’eux-mêmes
mais aussi leur rapport
au monde et donc à la vie.
Mais laissons de côté
ces cas particuliers.
La mort nous fascine en premier lieu
parce qu'elle est inimaginable.
Mais plus elle est spectaculaire
et plus elle va aiguiser notre curiosité.
Les 0,15% de morts violentes vont
faire couler beaucoup plus d’encre
et occuper nos écrans de télé
que les 80% de maladies de l’être humain.
On est en droit de se demander pourquoi.
Est-ce que c’est la part sombre,
cachée en chacun de nous
qui est stimulée ?
Nous allons voir ensemble
que les mécanismes
sont bien plus complexes.
L’être humain apprend par expérience.
Par nature, il est curieux
et il intellectualise
grâce à son apprentissage.
Mais est-ce qu’on peut
apprendre à mourir ?
Ce voyeurisme qui nous pousse à ralentir
sur l’autoroute devant un accident,
les 23 saisons de
« Faites entrer l’accusé »,
les scènes de guerre en boucle sur BFM,
ont pour but premier
de nourrir cette curiosité.
Curiosité morbide, je vous l'accorde.
Mais en somme, nous voulons
savoir ce que ça fait de mourir.
Si l’on s’arrêtait à ce phénomène,
les hôpitaux seraient
remplis de visiteurs.
Or, nous ne sommes pas
qu’en recherche de sens,
mais également de sensations
car nous sommes aussi des êtres sensitifs.
Nous allons donc rechercher
tout un tas de sensations
avec les deux grandes gagnantes
que sont la peur et le plaisir évidemment.
Essayons de se rappeler ensemble
de certaines scènes cultes du cinéma.
Je pense notamment à la scène
de la douche dans « Psychose »,
celle du téléphone dans « Scream »,
celle de l’égout dans « Ça »
ou encore celle du carton dans « Seven ».
Généralement, quand on la voit,
qu’est-ce qu’on ressent ?
La plupart d’entre vous
va ressentir du stress,
une certaine tension, de la peur
car on s’identifie naturellement
du côté de la victime.
Nous sommes pour beaucoup
d'entre nous des proies.
Les films d’horreur
mais également les fêtes foraines,
les sauts en parachute,
les cages à requins,
exploitent notre attirance pour la peur.
Car avoir peur,
c’est avant tout se sentir vivant
et quelque part, défier la mort.
Quand on ne s’identifie pas
du côté de la victime, de la proie,
qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
On peut bien sûr être indifférent
mais on peut aussi éprouver du plaisir.
On devient ce prédateur,
celui qui chasse, qui domine.
On assouvit son fantasme
de toute-puissance.
C’est bien plus rare, heureusement,
mais l’effet escompté reste identique.
On se sent vivant
en ressentant par procuration.
Les livres, les séries, les films
qui [rencontrent] le plus de succès
sont souvent ceux qui arrivent
à générer le plus d’identification.
C’est bien pour ça qu’on voit
ces derniers temps
une explosion du « True Crime »
à l’image de Jeffrey Dahmer
et de ses 700 millions
d’heures de visionnage.
Mais finalement, quoi de mieux
que de se confronter à la réalité
et de se poser cette fameuse
question un peu existentielle :
« Mais qu’est-ce que
j’aurais fait à sa place ? »
C’est ce qui nous amène
à notre troisième motivation :
la catharsis.
Extérioriser ses émotions, ses pulsions
comme son stress, sa peur, son plaisir
nous aide à nous sentir mieux.
Ce n’est pas moi qui suis agonisant
au bord de l’autoroute,
ce n’est pas moi qui suis
sous les bombes en Ukraine,
comme ce n’est pas moi qui prends
le risque de violer ou de tuer quelqu’un.
Je suis à distance,
confortablement assis dans mon canapé,
et je libère mes fantasmes
tout en nourrissant mon imaginaire
et mes connaissances, bien sûr.
En gros, j’apprends
ce qu’il faut faire et ne pas faire.
De fait, nous avons tous appris
que de se cacher sous son lit
ou dans son placard,
quand on est poursuivi
par un tueur sanguinaire,
même marchant au ralenti, je vous assure,
c’est une très mauvaise idée.
On aura au moins appris ça.
Après, soyons objectifs.
Quand je dis « on »,
ce sont surtout nous les femmes.
Car si on regarde de plus près
les crimes médiatisés ou fictionnels,
qu’observe-t-on ?
Oui, la plupart des victimes
sont des femmes.
Pourtant, il faut savoir que les hommes
ont quatre fois plus de risques
de mourir de mort violente
que leur partenaire.
Mais désolé, messieurs, il faut croire
que vous êtes moins sexy que nous.
Car si le crime nous stimule autant,
c’est qu’il est souvent érotisé.
Le criminel incarne le mâle en puissance.
Intelligent, ténébreux, charismatique,
à l’image de Ted Bundy
ou d’Hannibal Lecter.
La victime, elle, incarne
l’icône féminine de son époque,
souvent jeune, jolie
et, bien sûr, vulnérable.
La rencontre des deux
nous délecte de détails sordides,
faits de soutiens-gorge arrachés
de bas déchirés et
de petites culottes découpées.
Le crime sexualise la mort
et réveille ainsi nos pulsions
les plus primaires,
comme nos fantasmes les plus archaïques.
Vous l’aurez compris,
qui dit mort violente
dit forcément tueur en série.
Et c’est précisément ici qu’ils vont tirer
une grande part de leur célébrité.
Nous avons d’un côté le crime ordinaire,
souvent familial ou conjugal,
et de l’autre, l’extraordinaire,
fait de mobiles obscurs,
de pulsions destructrices,
souvent sexualisées, visant
de multiples victimes inconnues.
Donc, vous potentiellement.
Afin de mieux comprendre pourquoi
l’un est plus médiatique que l’autre,
prenons quelques exemples
bien de chez nous.
Dans la famille Crime Ordinaire,
je demanderais
monsieur Dupont de Ligonnès.
Je sais que ça ne vous paraît pas
si ordinaire que ça.
Il a quand même tué toute sa famille
avec préméditation, me direz-vous,
un somnifère chacun,
une balle de 22 long rifle
dans la tempe à bout portant.
Sa femme, ses quatre enfants
et même ses deux chiens
se sont retrouvés enterrés
sous sa terrasse dallée.
Mais ne vous y trompez pas,
s’il défie la chronique,
c’est principalement
parce qu’il est introuvable,
sinon son nom serait oublié
depuis bien longtemps.
Quand même, me dira-t-on,
c’est difficile à oublier.
Très bien, alors montons
d’un cran dans l’horreur.
Si je vous parle de cet homme qui a tué
à coups de pied de biche sa belle-sœur,
son beau-frère, sa petite nièce,
son neveu, il y a de cela six ans.
Il les a ensuite découpés
en tout petits morceaux.
Il a tout fait brûler dans la chaudière
sauf les os du crâne, trop résistants.
Et il a ensuite dispersé
les viscères dans son jardin.
Peut-être pour faire
de l’engrais, allez savoir.
Ça ne vous dit rien ?
A part quelques initiés ou passionnés
de criminologie, je pense que non.
L’affaire Troadec, du nom de ses victimes,
a pourtant fait la une des journaux.
Mais ce cher monsieur Caouissin
est parti rejoindre
la grande famille des faits divers.
Entre 700 et 800 homicides
en France par an,
un tiers sont des meurtres familiaux.
250 personnes,
ça en fait du monde à retenir.
Alors, on oublie, tout simplement.
Un peu comme les victimes d'ailleurs,
elles sont souvent moins populaires.
Ce n’est pas par manque d’empathie,
souvenez-vous,
nous sommes encore,
pour beaucoup d’entre nous, des proies.
C’est juste que personnellement,
ce qui nous intéresse,
ce qui aiguise notre curiosité,
c’est le danger auquel
elles sont confrontées.
C’est cela qui nous terrorise
ou nous fascine selon les cas.
Evidemment,
ces histoires restent fascinantes.
Et pour cause, c’est notre voisin,
notre cousin, notre collègue, notre oncle.
Le jeu de l'identification reste massif.
On se demande :
« Mais qu’est-ce qui pousse
un père de famille à tuer
ce qu’il a de plus cher ? »
On s’interroge et on compare
son vécu avec le sien.
Et on en revient encore
à cette fameuse question :
« Mon mari, ma femme, moi-même,
serait-on capable d’un tel acte ? »
Peut-être.
Par expérience, je vous dirais
quand même de vous méfier,
un adultère, un héritage
et les choses peuvent vite déraper.
Je plaisante, bien sûr.
Quoique.
Si, maintenant, pour finir,
je vous évoque Guy Georges.
Là, l’identification est
plus difficile, j’espère.
On se rapproche de ce que
l’on pourrait nommer le mythe.
L’imaginaire est dépassé.
Les tueurs en série sont les nouveaux
monstres de nos sociétés modernes,
à l’image des vampires
ou des loups-garous,
il y a quelques siècles.
Comme eux, Guy Georges a deux visages.
L’être humain, la journée
et le monstre sanguinaire, la nuit.
Il est le prédateur par excellence.
Celui qui chasse,
celui qui traque, celui qui rôde,
celui qui vous attaque dans le parking
ou dans votre lit pendant que vous dormez.
Il lacère, il poignarde,
il mutile, il strangule.
Mais lui, vous ne pouvez pas le raisonner
car il n’y a aucun affect
entre lui et vous.
C’est un peu comme une souris
qui supplierait un chat de l’épargner.
C’est grâce à ce petit plus
que les tueurs en série
deviennent aussi célèbres.
Comme les autres,
ils remplissent leurs quatre fonctions.
Curiosité, sensation,
extériorisation, fantasme,
mais en rajoute une cinquième,
celui de régulateur social.
Nous avons besoin de définir le mal,
le mauvais, le dangereux
pour se situer dans la société
à laquelle on appartient.
Et généralement, on préfère
se situer du côté du bien.
On va donc à la fois les humaniser,
en tentant de comprendre
leur histoire ou leur pathologie,
tout en les maintenant fermement
dans leur statut de monstre,
loin de nous.
C’est comme une frontière
morale de notre espèce,
c’est notre baromètre, notre régulateur,
la ligne à ne surtout pas franchir.
J’espère que vous comprendrez mieux
votre attirance pour le crime
et les morts violentes.
Mais sachez que
tout le monde ne l’est pas.
Tout le monde ne ralentit pas
sur l’autoroute,
ne lit des faits divers
ou ne zappe sur BFM
et beaucoup me fuient,
moi et mes histoires glauques
pendant les dîners.
Je dirais que ceux-là
sont ceux qui mettent le plus
de distance entre eux et la mort.
Ils la rejettent de toutes leurs forces.
Ils ne veulent ni la voir, ni y penser,
ni s'entraîner en quelque sorte.
Et peut-être qu’ils n’ont pas si tort.
Car je suis désolée de vous dire
qu’il n’y a rien à apprendre.
Nous n’allons pas mourir,
nous sommes déjà tous en train de mourir,
autant mettre son énergie ailleurs.
Peut-être dans l’apprentissage de la vie
parce qu’il paraît que c’est au moment
de mourir qu’on en fait enfin le bilan.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)